es la apuesta más popular de la
autodenominada izquierda progresista y
el personaje más mediático gustavo petro
originario del departamento de córdoba
creció y se inició como sindicalista
durante su adolescencia en zipaquirá a
los 17 años se hizo un militante de la
guerrilla m-19 conocido como el
comandante aureliano por la novela 100
años de soledad no dejó las armas y
firmó la paz hasta 1990 momento desde el
que la defiende como parte de su
programa político
metido en política desde que salió de la
guerrilla en 2006 fue elegido como el
senador con la tercera votación más alta
de la historia del país en 2011 se
convirtió en el alcalde de bogotá con
más del 32 por ciento de los votos pero
su mandato terminó estrepitosamente con
una revocatoria en su contra entre otros
motivos por la gestión del sistema de
basuras de bogotá el alcalde mayor de
bogotá independientemente quien se solo
puede ser destituido por causas
taxativas
escritas en la ley por el presidente de
república hablamos aquí un golpe estado
con dos intentos fracasados de conseguir
la presidencia del país en 2010 y 2018
respectivamente petro ha mantenido su
política centrada en la lucha contra la
pobreza la desigualdad y la corrupción
en el país no creo la verdad que haya
algún colombiano que crea que todo está
bien y ahora con sus políticas sociales
a favor del paro nacional del 2021 el
político representa un desafío a la
sucesión de gobiernos de derecha que han
ocupado el poder en colombia
históricamente el uno mismo
es el que ha generado las condiciones de
un cambio político no obstante a pesar
de su popularidad su figura genera gran
polarización entre la sociedad
colombiana